what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch Andor
episode 11 today joining me is uh the
co-host of the weekly Year
buddy I was going for are you okay it's
John how are you John I'm I'm doing okay
I think they should leave a like they
should subscribe and hit the
notifications
check out the patreon page for full
length reaction and or where you sync up
with your own cops there's other shows
too many other shows
by someone and the expressvpn we'll talk
more about them after the reaction
because we love expressvpn there's so
much just installed over the whole house
I use it to break into other people
sometimes we're so safe now we can just
privacy I know exactly VM we do have set
up in in this entire home it's amazing
so yeah we can't share with you guys all
right let's go do it
foreign
make some seaweed moccasins they're
leaving
I'm saying that
they're living
I can't climb back up
you hear me I hear you my hands won't
work I said I hear you
tell me to leave it
they're living
they're leaving
we'll save it for cassia okay
she would have wanted it that way
heartbreaking oh no
what about the Droid
no
what
oh my God
we're gonna take around a minute if you
want to say goodbye
oh
[Music]
I'll have them clear the room if you
want to be alone
I really don't want to be alone I want
mama Marva oh
poor guy I can Google go with you the
daughters of pharynx require your
assistance in matters of grave
importance we need to pull together B
all of us
you're a member of this resistance too
poor B
itch she die
under what circumstances
[Music]
oh I never wasn't even around for it
oh poor B
[Music]
it looks like it's just these two they
didn't walk here but if we go around
jump them and steal their clothes
yeah what uncomfortable conditions
even think that they never get back in
time if there's someone else either
we're getting out of you I know I feel
it God I feel every one of those stones
that's right right dude
[Music]
oh dude no
she love what's up they're building a
list of grievances we want a funeral
you're going to give them a permit limit
the time limit the numbers we want to
put them in a box stand back and watch
art draw him out to the public
the dead are bricked they mix your ashes
with mortar and local stone dust put
your name on and fire it up you become a
block of ferric's brick wow and then
what
they find you a wall
backgrounds of the city
what a metaphor
a thousand each one for each of us
that's a great makeup water spoil here
and foreign
hahaha
you Millennials bitching about the
Empire
what did he say
s
like some judge dredge [ __ ] damn where
would you be looking to run now eh
yeah what oh
I'm so uneasy
that was lucky wow what do you know
flies into the wall
street base I totally heard every word
they said definitely easy to make it no
problem turn off those subtitles would
you
he's about to get on edge
[Music]
Great Frame my cousin
I understand she shops here
senator mothma
tomorrow is too late where is he you're
off the rails you're lucky he's not here
not here I gave him eldani what have you
done lately
Trump
meow
I have always
I have a constant blur of plates
spinning and knives on the floor and
needy panicked faces at the window of
which you are but one of many
foreign
the mother died I'm leaving in the
morning
Center says it's very busy though
let him know
do that you two could have been Lovers
In Another Universe I was sitting here
going kiss kiss
cut the tension if Santa dies it'll
happen time could go back to my place
I'm charging she's not hereby
he's in the stone now
again we will wait to make sure
I'll leave you here alone is
Droid is breaking my heart
nice day
one night oh
best Droid in all of Star Wars I've gone
other way this episode to make him like
the most human aspect
s
oh God she's still there oh yeah
gotta break your mind oh
I'm going to ask you a question
if I'm not sure it's the truth I'll have
to call back Dr ghost
Anto Krieger
he's a big man
Big Man SpongeBob is this the man you
introduced to Cassie and Andor
fix
yes
oh she is so broken
foreign
you guys are way too far with your
torturing man now she's more tortures
you gotta have the right amount of
torture it's like the fine go on the
blocks at the right temperature
she loves it and her friends
the only thing she shows up on time for
it
really
she found the Elder
don't tell me you're taking proposals
I'm in so much trouble though
oh yeah you are but you're not a thug I
pulled everything I could access up the
hill into the main account
it was one empty Ledger at the end of
the line that was off balance
I don't make a Wells Fargo man
I really need a credit union Ma I went
to Lutheran I told him that I needed
help from the outside that I need the
risk take home
yes
and you trust him yes I do
wants an introduction man I thought tea
could help me replace the credits and
get me started again but what he really
did was discover just how much more
trouble I was in
oh
how much is missing
four hundred thousand
yikes
it's like 200 American dollars inflation
Galactic inflation just leaving now
not really
he warned me
who knows what he knows everything's
always right
I found a solution
he's got an invitation you know
Genevieve O'Reilly does not get enough
credit for how great she is in this show
absolutely not does not she's so good
just the amount here that's just like
falling apart and has to keep up a whole
facade oh oh she's so good I can hear
her soul cracking yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
just speak clearly indeed
I think I've been rugged for me lately
but you know
much
hey what's good
in the office helping with the Imperial
transition my old partner still work in
the HQ night desk you phoned me this
afternoon and he told me that
oh God the mother you were talking about
indoors
she's passed away and to her's mother
did lots of back and forth with Corazon
about her are you saying that he's there
no no I'm in Moana where is zandor
we need to speak further
no
the mystery of your former triumphs have
been vanquished
I can sleep peacefully now oh my God
murder her
and then switch off of atnt I think he
probably will kill his boss
he's got some Norman Bates in him
Master sneaker she never checked that
box I know nobody ever left that box all
those months I just left that box there
and whoever tends those rooms too
what's all this
the sound
Luther
do not with the speaker that took
Cricket help Krieger I'm in tell her to
bring air power it's taking a long time
coming back to me sir you were so eager
for it is being knows Krieger's plan
he'll be waiting for it and how do we
know this I won't tell you that
how do you know I won't tell him I don't
I don't know what you'll do
is far from ideal for either of us
throwing them into the dogs you're
willing to burn him
you're the random Factor so you know his
doomed which means either your ISB
or you have someone inside that you are
protecting or I'm just a very good
listener
worth
losing Krieger
he's an ox what if it was me what would
you do Krieger doesn't know me I'm not
vulnerable if he's captured
surely you've met him met him I've been
in a room with him but he doesn't know
that we send people we drop supplies we
have special radios he can't hurt me
like I can
we'll let Krieger go down and play the
long game or do we warn him and throw
away his sources taken years to
cultivate you have people everywhere
don't you you're avoiding the question
all of your sources try to concentrate
[Laughter]
someone with Krieger
ISP
maybe there's someone here with me
they're all fired
my man he tells me everything what is
this
what kind of game is this
Krieger goes down the ISP will feel
Invincible we'll have a clear field to
play
the alternative Craig pulls out we wave
him off
they'll know they'll have to wonder
trust nothing just like you're doing it
right now all right right yeah kill
creaker
laughs
and all this 30 minutes
I gotta make some ugly sacrifices
I killed vitamin for the greater good
call it what you will
call it where you will
War the star war that's a good scene I
know it's Forest Whitaker's best live
action scene yet I'm most curious about
the other piece you should come home
is no longer available
next we lose that and we'll have to
close shop I'm preparing for every
outcome
[Applause]
sorry Lutheran you're going out going
through a tunnel Lutheran I can't hear
you
oh no someone onto Lutheran
is our satellite Cruiser sorry could you
repeat back please
this is an imperial Patrol standby for
transponder scan ID foul
it's got a VPN yes this is all around
one two nine
stand by horcroft run it
run it Darth helmet
there's been partisan activity in the
area this is a piracy Zone oh thank you
for the warning oh I'll be careful
you'll be standing by it's what you'll
be doing oh my God
what no Lutheran it's time for space
travel speeches
I'm gonna slap that wig back on
oh [ __ ] disengage any propulsion units
and prepare to track the beacon
affirmative Patrol I have an engine
to jump to light speed tractor beam has
been engaged Warcraft
to power down your stabilizers
calibrary tractor Force calibrating
confirm request make a yo mama joke
sorry Patrol I'm a one-man show here I
have to manual these stabilizers
ID confirm sir alderon trade Alliance
cancel the boarding no
we can use the practice oh my God yeah
acknowledge
what are you doing tractor Force up five
does he think he can get away
who do you think he's gonna go
final warning whole craft power down
immediately or risk full consequences
slam what are full consequences
countermeasures armed
Wowie
oh
my God sick
from a whole Croft practical Beacon is
failing us I can see that where's my
Airway my shop is expiring
Tie fighters
go Luther
you're the greatest pilot
Booyah broke their giant Wang beam
damn another one down
[Music]
so cool
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
we're great to tell you
that was great
so proud of you
just shakes his head ruins of your
career right there is that one Freight
excuse me where's this
oh dang
calcium
I mean who
tell her I'm thinking about her she'd be
proud of me and I'll get back as soon as
I can can you remember that
your mother's dead
or a guy wrongfully thrown in jail well
if we're the only ones somebody's got to
tell people what's happening right there
we need to split up
double our chances
one of us has to make it
people have to know what's going on
I tell five friends you tell five
friends they each tell five friends
people have to know about this
[Music]
oh dude
they've been through the ringer together
[Music]
it's the same kind of visual he would
look at
what he left with Marva
always comes back to her
ah
really just how much Tony Gilroy hate
Star Wars just really leaks through
every time it's so slow
all right okay let's talk about it
because there's a lot to talk about all
right but before we talk about the
sandor stuff we got to think today's
video sponsor
expressvpn uh really grateful to them
for not only sponsoring this channel
once again but for keeping all of our
online business safe and secure whether
encrypted services and IP address
masking now I want to get this out of
the way yes many of us know what it's
like to use a Google incognito window
thinking it's safe and not traceable but
you'd be wrong I was scared to learn
this I first started on a Mr Sunday
movies ad and then we looked it up and
yeah we should mention it too going
incognito on Google Chrome is good and
all until you realize that Google makes
fortunes by its users online activity
and you can bet a little incognito
window isn't going to get in the way of
that and they've literally am I they we
mean Google have said as much claiming
that Incognito does not mean invisible
whilst facing a five billion dollar
class action lawsuit here in California
for secretly collecting user data so
yeah guys we use a VPN because we've had
some scary situations happen to us there
was one I've never been public about but
it was a nightmare to deal with behind
the scenes and fortunately we were able
to solve it but yeah implementing a VPN
has been a necessity and definitely
highly encouraged that everyone uses it
now you have other options for vpns you
could use expressvpn as the one the real
rejects here have chosen to have stuck
with since day one and of course you
know one of the best parts about it you
know other than protecting your IP
address your personal info and your
other sensitive online activity it would
be when you're trying to watch Netflix
in other countries and you see the shows
they get access to when you connect it
to like oh I connected my VPN in Japan
what that's what they get in Japan they
get all the good stuff in Japan you get
all the best stuff friends in Japan
Maybe
do you think so I don't know a lot of
other people who aren't America get
friends and that's the important thing
that's the important change you can pick
anywhere in the world you want to be and
see what that Library looks like it's
amazing man every time you connect
you'll get a random IP address shared by
other expressvpn customers making you
harder to identify and your data more
difficult to harvest it's super easy to
use to the point that one tap
essentially protect your phone laptop
Smart TV all your dudes wow they really
want you to know like how easy it is to
use it yeah no expressvpn you got to fix
your talking so easy it's so much easier
than that you just select the country
and you press a button there you go then
you hit go it's like when you hit go on
any machine you just go it's going and
that you're safe you're insane there you
go now you're in that country who needs
to travel too many words expressing you
can turn on the VPN so if you really
truly want to go Incognito and protect
your privacy secure yourself with the
number one rated VPN visit expressvpn
dot com slash Rejects and get three
extra months free that's
[Music]
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com rejects I wanted
us to spell it out for you yeah in case
you can read it because e is in Edward
go to expressvpn.com rejects to learn
more uh if we can make fun of them we've
been using them already before they paid
us to talk about that yeah absolutely
yeah and you could bet the someone like
Lutheran rail knows the value of a good
uh VPN the death of
so
that was really sad man yes that was a
very somber episode I was very really
sad everyone's broken it's the Dark
Night of the Soul
uh before we get to the finales would
have felt like to me next week's the
finale yeah
yeah
normally it's like an All Is Lost
moment the death of Marva yeah yeah yeah
and just them being entirely ostensibly
alone the two of them for now I mean
even with Bix she's like so broken
they've done a number on her man holy
[ __ ] yeah that was to the point where I
was like is she ever gonna like is her
is her brain gonna be scrambled just
from here on out like is she gonna have
to like have someone take care of her
for the rest of her life due to this
she's like that horror movie character
you visited an insane asylum when you're
looking for answers she hasn't been able
to talk clearly in years you won't get
anything out of her and she's like rips
your ass
for you
remember this code yeah yeah totally
yeah she's really morphed
yeah and I mean it's funny how like one
you only see her for like one brief
sequence but it's
among every like everything no matter
how brief it is always seems to come
with like a lasting punch and impact
like no matter how I like it it's it's
interesting to see a show where yeah
it's like you have a lot of characters
and a character that could feel small
just showing up for one moment in an
episode rarely ever gets lost in the
shuffle like they're really good at
making everyone's time important true
whether that be through yeah you know
direct advancement of the plot or just
heartbreaking circumstance
well what's her name Clea yes the the
Sona Sona yeah yeah I'm waiting for CLIA
to because I like the presence of Cleo
still waiting to latch onto her more as
a character though she's kind of just
there to whip some things into shape
she I think she rides the line well
because she is this sort of like
executive assistant who you can tell
probably does a lot of badass and
difficult [ __ ] behind the scenes but
mostly we just see her being very direct
and this episode in particular I was
like okay this is like the most we've
sort of seen you in action and I want to
know more about you now yeah yeah but to
me I think like Vel and and um Genevieve
O'Reilly Mon mothma it's cool this is
the first time I felt like they were
really cousins yeah there was a real
history with them and I I think just the
slowly broken soul of mon mothma and the
sacrifice that she really had to make
because you know it's sometimes in this
act of rebellion it's more like yeah you
got political figures with money who are
secretly helping out
um and then here with mon mothma you you
really see that she wasn't just secretly
helping out that she was truly
instrumental but she also had to make
some of the toughest choices of her
personal life and sacrificed so much and
how much sacrifice can she keep enduring
until enough is enough like how far
can she go is she willing to give up her
family in like the most literal ways
it's really painful to see what she goes
through and like I I feel like even when
like last episode you know like like the
highlights or the monologues of like
Andy Circus and stellen Skarsgard
uh but Mama did have a really powerful
scene she's been so consistent and then
uh her scene here would vowel when
they're sitting on the couch together
you know braiding each other's hair
painting his nails having a pillow guys
that's right
do you think Luther is cute I think
Luther is cute no you don't shouldn't I
want Luther no you when they are uh when
they aren't talking with each other just
it just keeps getting worse and worse
for her and my notion of what her
pivotal she would be would be more
that hopeful Spirit of the of the Rebel
excuse me the rebel rising and Dawning
in the middle of my Rebellion yeah I'm
sorry but it didn't turn into that at
all uh it's it is crazy just how
relatable of a figure they have made her
and not just one of the nice people from
Coruscant yeah well because she suffers
this makes it clear how much she suffers
in silence and like she's already got
Perrin who's a real winner but you know
even with her daughter it seems like you
know her family can't really know her
and she can't really be like emotionally
close to the people who do know her
because of what they have to work on so
it seems like a very it really Clues who
into how harsh her position is and I did
love getting a moment between Vel and
Clea
and and that whole you know like Val I
like the way they draw the fact that
yeah you have their familial tie but you
also have both of their ties to the
rebellion and how different those things
are and how in one doing their job that
can step on the other's Toes or make the
other's life that much more difficult
and it it's just like a really
fascinating Nuance that they don't
really even necessarily have to speak
all the time but yeah especially here it
felt like they were even in the
emotional beats like actually yeah it's
funny you should say because yeah they
do feel
like actually related I can see the
sisterly kind of Rapport between them
and it's funny because this is an
episode that has so much Humanity
despite all the you know vicious
circumstance and I love that they chose
to make be like the most vulnerably
emotional character even going so far as
to start like inside of his vision
inside of his eye just inside of like
his perspective when so much of the rest
of the episode is shot in ways that are
very illustrative of isolation you know
and Val and clear are talking they're
both talking to negative space
essentially uh and all these like when
marva's being carted out it's all in
these wides like there's so much
uh of the sterility and of the distance
created and I thought it was an
interesting way to to pull everything
together yeah well I think would be too
he's a lot of times with droids
they one thing I've always liked about
Star Wars when it came to the artificial
intelligence if you will is that they
've never sometimes they throw those
bits of like shut the ripio off just
turn them off he's being annoying you
know yeah but more often than not they
treat droids like they actually have
souls yeah and that they're they are a
living being
and I love that this show really leans
into that would be too and the same
people would create to us so you know
like the Tony Gilroy and so it would be
too the
he is like a child lonely pet and uh I
just feel so much compassion for him of
a destroyed learning humanity and it
makes me worried for him I wonder what
life be to ultimately has because he's
not a rogue one
so what Journey does he go with your
mates with other droids have baby droids
there are two possible outcomes either
he does a daring sacrifice the last
minute that allows the rebels to get
away one one more time or there will be
one of those like cassium again like go
on boy get out of here yeah go on I I
don't need you anymore go it's for your
good you know just
uh yeah there are some things that I
wish we would get a little bit more
fleshing out on
like and or melshi that moment would hit
a little bit harder for me
other than the poignant themes of Rise
of rebellion and such
like I don't even really know who this
guy is like I wish we had gotten a
little bit more time to
see live with their survival because I
was enjoying the survival tone
of of just being like something that was
like borderline you know like those
survival movies and nature of like the
edge or Revenant or some [ __ ] because
you know like they're they're Barefoot
and Barren cold harsh wastelands and
yeah it's it's so it's so isolated and
and such a vulnerable situation to be in
in the most physical way and to me I'm
like I wish we got to see was some
friendship bond with them so we could
hear like that way you feel a little bit
more of a emotional impact when they are
like we have to tell everyone or feel
like what they've overcome together to
get there
that part I feel was a little bit
glossed over like it was good what we
got I did feel we needed more of what of
that though well yeah you could fill out
like a webisode or for my money you
could fill a whole episode for them to
having to stick it out and then finally
get off world and and then they you know
go back to the beach and find his case
and all that stuff there's a lot of
emphasis on um Lolita leader leader the
daughter of Mama yeah there's a lot of
emphasis on her and
I I guess kind of feel like whenever we
see her she's in a mood and the horse
she's happy to be in a good mood today
if it is Chandra Leone girl yeah I want
to I want to I want more is that over
near the end I'm like there's emphasis
put here and you're kind of just like
Moody kid yeah yeah and then this
episode with them being like you know oh
she she's really into you know this uh
you know this this Spirit you know the
the
is it that they're studying the customs
of like the arranged marriage and stuff
like that is that what she's studying at
the table there with her friends dude
whatever they're getting into each other
Customs or whatever yeah like the the
the old one they barely talk they just
barely Focus the spotlight on them boys
that feel nuanced that is the one way in
which the it does feel like the show is
like oh yeah we're not really that
concerned with her and and I think it
could say something and add more to both
mod mothma's character but also latest
character if we did maybe drip into her
perspective for a second and see what
she likes about these customers that mon
mothma isn't necessarily trying to
thrust upon her or whatever yeah because
that's all part of the conversation as
well and especially because it seems
like Lita skews more towards Perrin is
probably like I doubt that my mother
could full-on just reliably say I could
trust Leta if she were to find out all
the extent of what I've been doing here
so like it yeah I feel like you could
explore an interesting realm of
indoctrination and through that which
yes pretty glossed over here and then
glossing over it it does feel like you
have moody teenagers are still over
there just not connecting with me you
know and
I think this is one I'd probably get the
most push back on because whenever you
say something you got an issue with
there's always someone who comes in to
tell you why actually and I'm open to it
you know I respect that you know tell me
the the the more positive perspective of
this you know
um you hope zero wins okay yeah Cyril
needs to win they could be like here's
my certificate of approval mama I got a
job in the actual Empire no more private
security for me you know but I'm married
she tells me what to do against my
cereals
um she masculates me on the daily no I
love her teachers is morphed into oh
you're that one who appears in the
monitors looking evil now yeah yeah who
needs it done and done now
um the Krieger I I wish we see him uh
instead of just hearing about him
because
I get the choice because no one's really
spending time with him so it could just
feel kind of random to just cut to him
like you're not even Lutheran knows him
uh like Luther knows him but Krieger
doesn't know that Lutheran is Lutheran
yeah and so I I like I I can see that
the reasoning to not cut to him but
there's so much talk about him and
there's so much of a debate about what
to do with the Krieger situation should
they just sacrifice him or should they
help him but by helping him that takes
care of the ISB officer that you know
like there's there's a dangerous him so
I I love the debate and I love the scene
with saw Guerrera because you know saw
is like the ultimate case of a paranoid
junkie sure and and as I love saw a
scene and like I think that's all great
and it's wonderful debate like it does
not eliminate at all
um how how wonderfully fleshed out these
these uh scenes of dialogue are
and to be it's it's more like
I I guess it makes the debate what I
like about it is
it makes the debate strictly about the
morality choice and the and the and the
choice of sacrifice even if you don't
know who they are which is much like War
yeah you're like we gotta go save this
these people or these people are in
danger but they don't know them people I
know or my allies are about to be
sacrificed to one degree or another yeah
so like ending on that note of I call it
War colored War
I am the perfect person
that's me cuts my breath before we rise
uh I wonder if we would but I I but I'm
saying I would uh I would
uh
find it just more
I guess
it makes sense to not show him because
it just puts you in the position they're
in where you're kind of choosing as an
audience member whereas if you're
hanging out with Krieger you might just
be like well go save him he's Krieger
yeah I can't lose Krieger yeah we like
creakers yeah but removing that for the
audience makes us just think about the
debate itself that's why I see the
strength in it
um and and I I just kind of want the
emotional conflict more and I would be
more conflicted if I knew Krieger just a
little bit yeah that's a good point and
it it makes me wonder if we will see
that happen in some way next episode
before he gets his own Disney plus
series
that'll be the new trend of how to do
good Star Wars series is get characters
we know are going to die at the end or
or will die we've seen them die already
or something and then yeah we can tell a
story and leave nothing on the FL on the
credits don't even say who plays that
they're out of this face and it's not
the guy from Borat it's not Ken Davidian
that would be awesome uh yeah I I wonder
if we will see it in some way I mean
again judging by how certain things were
handled especially in this episode but
have been handled throughout I wonder if
whatever Glimpse we do get will still be
removed somehow sure yeah but I could
also Imagine doing some kind of thing
where you have the Echoes of this debate
or something that isn't that battle
maybe intercutting with that operation
going sour or something like that right
it just seems like
because they established that this
thing's like happening tomorrow and we
can move immediately uh
you know and we've had this as a thread
and like they've talked enough it would
also just help to see Krieger so that
you know it's it's among many names and
places thrown it's thrown out there that
are in conversation that aren't always
on screen so it would just be easier to
keep track of anyway but uh but also
yeah I feel like they've done enough
building on this the same way they kind
of did without Donnie where it's like
they they laced that in and built it up
and I feel like it it would factor in
but if it doesn't uh I I think
I I agree with you in the context of
this episode I'll be more maybe vexed
about it if we just never see it before
The Season's done but it's interesting
yeah
Cyril Rising he had the funniest scene
in the whole world
there was uh what we got we got two
tubes credited here I read that wrong
the first time I don't know I know who
that is
I like two tubes too pick one and pick
two yeah
uh the Zone
yeah
and I feel like there's uh oh yes and
dude luton's fight scene yeah that was a
great fight yeah that was a great fight
he pulled some [ __ ] out of his ass he
did he turned on his VPN John Wick the
Empire if you wanted to dude he seems
like you really could it's like he just
took out like five Tie fighters see what
just happened here in a ship that's
probably not designed to take down five
thai fighters because they
underestimated him that's true he took
them all out I mean it was like one of
those spy cars where you're like look at
this piece of [ __ ] that you find it's
equipped with all like all kinds of like
strips
toothpaste launcher whatever you need
oil slick yeah this is so cool
um and he just whooped their asses it
was like so fast yeah and that dude just
stand there watch did he get out of oh
what are those called the
the magnet puller thing as well tractor
beam
um I did
release the tractor beam uh
one million billion credits he he really
he gets added not only does he break out
of the tractor beam he also whoops a
bunch of TIE fighter asses I was like
God damn how did this guy not make it to
Rogue one I know well he's gonna I bet
he's gonna die terribly I I feel like he
has to make it through the season too
but he's he's gonna they're gonna make
an example of him I'm sure cardiac
arrest you think yes he's gonna die
completely unrelated he's just gonna
slip and fall down a big flight of
stairs break his neck they're gonna be
like [ __ ] a lot of stress that guy has
there's so many plans he didn't tell us
about
what do we do
yeah
I just love how things ramp up the
colder he gets like the further they get
in this fight the colder he has to
become and and like the more his
struggle to maintain his morality is
like a logical Endeavor yeah you know
the whole thing about it like I love
partly that scene between him and saw
because it is like I'm giving you the
choice you clearly seem to have like
less dirt on your metaphorical hands
right right like also I'm leveraging you
also I'm trying to make you see what I
see but also also I think I need this
like Clash of Vitality is just to make
sure that I'm still here as a moral
being because of how much I have to
operate in the tools and means that you
know my enemy does so true yeah
um good good [ __ ] but hey what are you
gonna do right what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do [ __ ] happens
sometimes your mom dies
but Andrew finding out that is really
sad man and if Bix
doesn't probably gonna attend the
funeral
no I'm sure she doesn't
and I don't like part of me wonders if
she will ever recover and part of me
thinks she won't and part of me thinks
that's cold but also bold when she has
makeup on that means she's recovered
that's right she's a wonderful character
recovering your lips are all pale and
your eyes are sunken in your whole soul
has been destroyed but you clean up nice
no I respect them for putting her out of
makeup sure because I'm it bothers me in
shows when they're like too afraid to
put their actor I mean she's obviously
wearing makeup she did lip swag for
torture film makeup to enhance
the physical distress turmoil she's in
the no makeup makeup but
they did it yeah make her like oh let's
pretty her up despite this terrible
situation she said
um yeah because obviously she is
oh my God like horrendous looking woman
what you really got to be worried about
is the guy who sees this episode and
goes that's your best look baby
be wary of that guy yeah no Audrey
Arjona is a gorgeous woman she is um and
a talent to behold as well
yeah guys uh what did you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down
below
and uh yeah I'm just [ __ ] I'm yawning
all right let's uh
let's give it to do a patreon
[Laughter]
you I've been here for 55 months that's
over four years you've served in the
rain check for belly
thank you Mikhail for being part of our
patreon for so long man damn I just
looked at your address for the first
time I will never know how to pronounce
that or write it on an envelope wow in a
way that gets to you crap how does that
make any sense so for the amount of time
you've been with us um
you have never swayed once you've always
been very encouraging and kind
and I think all we know is that you're
from Sweden and you like James Bond and
I think after a few years we want to
know a little bit more consistent
character in this universe they knew
exactly who you were when they wrote you
words quirks just lean into that all the
time how do you relate to a James Bond
character haha yeah so it's kind of
funny that you know to see you I don't
think you've changed your profile pic
once this whole time no I love it never
change it uh but Mikhail
you're a beautiful guy you're you're a
gem you know that your Swedish gem
and uh you're hotter than all the
Swedish girls out there like I'm gonna
type in Swedish girls don't do that on
Google no why what happens uh you know
I'm sure you've got a virus I'm sure
it'll be appropriately appropriate for
Swedish girls myths about Swedish women
confirmed and busted Mikhail oh my God
these women these are women
oh oh dude they're like Audrey arahono
without makeup oh god get a feeling get
it off my screen how to impress Swedish
women the comprehensive guy just the
first article what it's not like
impressing any other kind of woman let
me tell you hail you have been uh tell
them you know Michaela that's not your
sweet you've been living it up Mikhail
so congratulations on all the success
I'm very proud of you
all right we'll talk soon buddy
foreign
[Music]